tropas rusas en movimiento su destino es
desconocido mientras la guerra continúa
las fuerzas rusas han capturado
importantes zonas de ucrania incluyendo
chernóbil sapodilla y gerson pero los
avances no son tan rápidos como algunos
esperaban los rusos encuentran
resistencia en casi todas las ciudades
que permanece bajo control ucraniano
pero se están preparando para un asalto
o se van mientras pueden
en las afueras de la capital la ciudad
de irving está en ruinas destruida por
los bombardeos mientras los residentes
se apresuran a escapar a pesar de que la
ciudad fue arrasada todavía no hay
rendición oficial la segunda ciudad de
ucrania harkov ubicada a 500 kilómetros
de kiev ha sido blanco impecable de los
misiles rusos
este hospital está lleno de civiles
atrapados en el fuego cruzado entre
ellos de más de 8 años herido por la
metralla
porque estábamos todos en casa el
proyectil impactó en el apartamento y
explotó dentro e incendio dos partes del
edificio cogimos algunas cosas
documentos y tal como estábamos en
pijama escapamos mi madre también sufrió
está en cuidados intensivos tiene
costillas rotas y daños en la columna
vertebral los médicos la trataron pero
el niño sufrió la peor reacción solo al
sur la ciudad portuaria de odessa
representa un objetivo clave para el
ejército ruso ya con el control de
gerzón y marío paul bajo asedio o dehesa
les daría a los invasores el dominio
total del mar negro y de todas las
importaciones a ucrania